i'm really curious as actors who have
worked across different genres and on
film and television
what will be a project that you would
love to see come to life
if money and time were no objects gina
i'll start with you
i mean i have like 72 projects do you
are you going to fund them dudes because
i would love to involve you
i would fund them all you know
you know what in all honesty if money
and time like lots of um
as a producer as somebody who is trying
to get projects out there from
you know uh communities that aren't as
uh heavily represented on screen
if money and time were no object then i
would be able to support all the new and
up-and-coming artists that i have
that i believe are so extremely talented
that just need the chance they just need
someone to take the chance on them and i
have like 72 no i'm kidding but i have a
bunch then i i really uh for me it's all
about like finding the people that have
not had the opportunity to do the thing
that i know they're capable of doing
i mean just to touch on what gina said
um
i started thinking of like i would
really just love
a good whether it be tv or film limited
series a good
filipino story you know something that
happens
i i was gonna say to not i not meaning
that i want to be selfish but it isn't
selfish it's i wanna
i wanna share that i'd love to share
something like that with the world and
show that aspect
yeah to different cultures and
communities
yeah so something that revolved a good
filipino story would be amazing
yeah i would love that as well yeah i
would love that as well so it's not
selfish i agree
yeah and so this movie is all about
relationships and how chaotic they are
and also you know how educational they
can be sometimes i'm curious what is the
greatest advice you've ever gotten about
a relationship that's helped you grow as
a person um and manny this time i'll
start with you um
i will say i'm learning a lot about
myself right now
through these
questions and through these interviews
um
uh i the first thing that pops into my
head i don't know if it's i mean it's
advice that i'm taking literally right
now but it's
to really work and something that i have
believed in is to work on yourself you
know at first i think
um
to be able to spend some time alone
uh go through some growth by yourself
first and
to love yourself first and then
and then maybe after that you can
somebody else can come in and love you
just as much
i think along those lines is a good
piece of advice
and gina
best piece of advice is tell the truth
from the beginning who you are and how
that might change and how that might
shift and um
and just to always be expressing
communicatively your truth and i think
that that uh was pretty good advice
because i did that with this last one
and it's lasted
[Laughter]
amazing amazing okay and uh manny so
just i'm a huge fan of uh your fiance
diane's work especially on warrior i
spoke with her last season i love her we
love it i love that it's coming back for
another season i'm curious
um if you were
to be will you be interested in guest
starring or doing being some part of
that show i mean
i'm just saying i think you would be
amazing in it
oh thank you thanks therese um
[Music]
yeah i mean we talk about all i'm always
like hey uh diane a is there room for a
guy who's around 511 you know um
athletic build uh you know has
um
really wants a job right now
um
it's uh yeah i know uh
i'd love to be able to to work on such a
and i don't say this just because
you know she's my partner it's such a
great tv show and i hope the world will
see it but we're not promoting that show
right now we're promoting this but yes i
would love
to to be a part of that um that world it
would be it would be incredible yeah
i had to ask i had to ask i you know one
of my favorites thank you for asking
and um gina so
obviously you have played jane as jane
the virgin for quite a long time and i
love that show i'm very curious when it
comes to anna your character and your
character
if this movie was a telenovela
who would she end up with ultimately in
the grand scheme of things
scott eastwood's character
absolutely
right she'd end up with a guy she
doesn't even know and how did she end up
meeting him and how did it get that far
um yeah she'd or she'd end up with uh
jenny slate's character
oh
okay i like that i was writing that i
like that a lot that's who she'd end up
with
um
yeah so i'm curious when it comes to a
movie like this and you guys have such
good chemistry on set and you just it
feels like you guys are just bouncing
off of each other all the time what was
it like uh cultivating that chemistry
and cultivating the uh the bonds that
you guys formed
it was
easy
it was it really felt seamless um
yeah i don't know what it was i don't
know if it was purposeful or if it was
just coincidental but we all just had
um respect for one another
um
and we all just had fun with one another
and felt open to play with one another
it was uh yeah
right yeah
it was easy right yeah
i don't even think that there was much
like cultivating that was done there was
like this organic desire and like love
like i think we all kind of love the i
mean i loved all of them before i met
them and like had already you know like
had my own like imaginary relationship
before i left them and you know played
out several conversations i would have
them you know
you guys don't do that
[Music]
um the conversation went really well in
my head and then it went really well in
real life and no i feel like me and
manny went on a hike in the way
beginning and i was like oh it's my
brother this is my brother for life like
i
and i also i'm in love with his wife and
warrior and yes agreed and i'm so happy
i am very curious so your characters
obviously interact with the other
characters as well
is there a c is there a character that
particularly maybe you didn't get to
spend enough time with that you wish
that maybe
you got some some scenes with or some
dialogue with that you know i'd be
interested in hearing about that um yeah
i didn't get to spend that much time
with charlie um it was you know it was
mainly gina and jenny and myself um
and which was amazing but also i just i
would hear stories of charlie
through gina and jenny and just being
like man i wish i could
play with them i wish i could you know
be in more scenes with them so yeah i
think charlie was
definitely a dude that i would love to
have had more scenes with for sure
what about you
we didn't get to play with like the
other relationships so like scott and
clark we didn't get to play with and i
really loved both of them so much and i
would have i mean you know it's inherent
in the script so you know you're not
going to but when we used to all hang on
and said it'd be like oh it'd be so much
fun to be like in more like in more
scenes i think we like one scene with
them you know
you know on the boat
that time while we were shooting on the
boat i was like oh it would have been so
dope to be like on set with them more um
because the ones that i got to be with
on set were awesome so it's like you
definitely just
you know
you can't i feel like i can't be greedy
i definitely had a great time you know
with
annie jenny and charlie i i yeah i can't
be greedy i really loved it
i loved it too i mean some of those
scenes were
genuinely hilarious i was like dying
laughing at someone else like oh man the
situation is
about to be wild
um yeah it was just
a very very funny movie very charming
and i really want to thank you guys for
speaking with me and taking the time
thank you so much for supporting our
movie appreciate you thanks terese thank
you so much thanks
you